c'est extraordinaire que cela puisse
sembler à ceux qui ne vivent pas aux
états unis il n'existe pas en amérique
un système comparable aux assurances
sociales
déjà dans les années 60 l'absence d'un
régime général d'assurance maladie
obligatoire aux états unis étonné le
président américain de l'époque lyndon
johnson démocrates allaient totalement
bousculé les codes en mettant en place
pour la première fois une aide pour les
personnes âgées le medicare est donc un
début un début que le président kennedy
n'avait pas pu obtenir bien qu'il
l'avait fortement des yeux après
l'instauration du medicare pour les plus
âgés et du medicaid la même année pour
les personnes sans ressources plus rien
bien au contraire
les présidents nixon puis reagan
quelques années plus tard ont favorisé
l'essor des compagnies d'assurance
privées en 1992 à la veille de
l'élection du démocrate bill clinton
le constat était amer 37 millions
d'américains n'avaient pas de couverture
sociale
pour moi c'est incompréhensible nous
sommes l'un des pays les plus riches du
monde et les gens peuvent pas spé
d'assurance
c'est épouvantable une fois élu bill
clinton promet une couverture maladie
pour tous c'est sa femme hillary clinton
qui portera cette réforme ambitieuse
mais le plan sera torpiller de toutes
parts quatre ans plus tard elle
expliquait les raisons de cet échec
il s'agit des compagnies d'assurances
entre autres qui ont dépensé quelques
300 millions de dollars pour leurs
campagnes de publicité négative contre
le programme de réformes
il faudra attendre 2009 et l'arrivée de
barack obama à la maison blanche pour
que la réforme du système de santé soit
de nouveau au coeur du débat nécessaire
pour certains liberticide et contre les
valeurs de l'amérique pour d'autres
nous aimons la liberté et lui est opposé
malmenés barack obama sera obligé
d'édulcorer sa réforme mais elle est
adoptée en 2010 et dans quelques jours
une lutte d'un siècle trouvera son
aboutissement dans un vote historique
les personnes les plus pauvres ont
désormais accès à des aides fiscales
pour se payer une assurance santé
devenue obligatoire le vote de ce soir
n'est pas la victoire d'un parti c'est
leur victoire la victoire du peuple
américain
mais cette assurance obligatoire ne
ravit pas tout les américain donald
trump en tête dès sa campagne
il promet d'abroger l'obamacare mais en
il n'a pas réussi à rassembler assez de
votes au congrès
la meilleure chose que nous puissions
faire maintenant sur le plan politique
c'est de laisser exploser l'obamacare
qu'il est même déjà en train d'exploser
la maison blanche a ensuite essayé de
faire abroger l'obamacare par voie
judiciaire
actuellement en pleine pandémie de
covile 19
le système de santé met en lumière les
inégalités forçant donald trump à faire
voter au congrès une loi rendant
gratuits les tests de dépistage ou
qu'ovide 19
[Musique]